my life sucks I have nothing going for
me really means I have nothing to lose
every position has advantages and
disadvantages and a lot of people look
at the really big guys and they're like
man must be easy for Alex I remember
when we had gym watch and we had a very
big company I would tell the guys who
were coming I was like if you're trying
to compete against me I was like you
have advantages I was like if you're on
a sales call you're like listen you're
just a number to Alex you're never gonna
talk to Alex with me you're going to get
my attention I'm the one I was like
that's how you're gonna throw stones at
me I was like but on the flip side if
it's me marketing to the masses I'm
gonna be like this kid's in his mom's
basement he has no idea what he's doing
he's been in business for 12 months and
of course he has no idea like wouldn't
you want somebody who's thousands of
success stories behind it because we've
made a system both sides have advantages
and so what happens is people are in
this small position where you can flip
the fact that you have nothing going for
you with you have nothing to lose you
can take lots of risks very quickly end
up in the exact same position you are
which is nothing Jack butcher says you
get rich by taking lots of risk with
small amounts of money and you stay Rich
by taking small amounts of risk with
lots of money yes